hello everyone do you like software as a
service model for your applications
have you ever wondered how to overcome
the challenge of sasured option I am
Praveen rajashekar responsible for
marketing kubernetes services and today
I am going to share how Google Cloud can
help you easily transform your
applications into multi-tenant
architecture and transform them into SAS
models
let's get started
[Music]
multi-tenancy is the single biggest
challenge for SAS adoption
let us examine a couple of different
contexts
as a service provider you may need to
deploy Your solution to multiple
customers and isolate consumers of your
service
this is usually the multi-customer
scenario primarily external
for instance jfrog as a SAS on Google
cloud with many customers accessing the
same application or as a platform team
you may need to isolate teams and
environments such as development staging
production
this is typically the multi-team
scenario internally within an
organization
for instance finance and HR teams
sharing same cluster for different
applications and environments while the
engineering teams supporting different
lines of businesses might require
isolated environments that are not
shared
one size doesn't fit all for SAS there
are various architectural drivers for
isolation such as security and privacy
requirements service level agreements
support for end user customizations data
sovereignty and business continuity
requirements
on the other hand operational drivers
for consolidation such as hosting costs
per tenant cost optimization shared
infrastructure costs and developer
productivity also play a significant
role in choosing the type of tenancy
there are also key design consideration
for multi-tenant application
architecture such as Regulatory and
compliance needs data severity
requirements application modernization
with a choice of virtual machines or
containers
the ability to drive spend and cost
reduction while maximizing business
value and adapting it operations to
evolving business needs
these help balance the need for
architecture isolation versus
operational consolidation tip
tips multi-tenant requirements include
quick onboarding
specify day two operations managing
security at scale ensuring slos are met
24x7 especially during Peak usage
and ability to accurately meter and
charge back now let us look at how
Google Cloud can help you meet those
requirements without changes to your
application
Yes you heard it right without changes
to your application by bringing in
isolation at the infrastructure layer
using infrastructure isolation at Google
Cloud project level you can maintain
data severity for Enterprise customers
you can use anthos config management and
customize the open source software to
support the free tire customers in the
most cost effective way through
self-service onboarding
to enable efficient sasops and for
Effective scalability and maintenance
you can leverage the most automated and
scalable fully managed kubernetes Google
kubernetes engine also known as gke
with fully managed autopilot mode of
operation combined with
multi-dimensional auto scaling
capabilities you can get started with a
production ready secure cluster in
minutes and have complete control over
the configurations and maintenance
especially with In-Place upgrades and
zero downtime
gke can run 15 000 node clusters
outscaling other Cloud providers by up
to 10 times letting you run applications
effectively unreliably at scale you can
optimize your kubernetes resources with
actionable insights
use gke cost optimization insights
workload right sizing and cost estimator
built right into the Google Cloud
console
to apply the same security principles
consistently across all tenants you can
use identity award proxy and identity
platform
with anthos multi-cloud you get a
framework to support the SAS application
to run close to your customer data
across multiple clouds and data centers
you can Implement efficient metering
uncharged back with the combination of
apigee metering for apis anthos service
mesh and GK emittering for shared
infrastructure resources and Google
Cloud project for billing isolation
moreover you can create a self-service
cost dashboard to improve transparency
using looker or data Studio dashboards I
hope you got a sneak peek of how various
services from Google Cloud can help you
easily transform your applications into
multi-tenant architecture and transform
them into SAS models
all without any application changes just
by bringing isolation at the
infrastructure layer thank you for your
time today don't forget to like And
subscribe to the channel and check out
the offer in the description below to
get started on your SAS transformation
today
[Music]